today on the matt wall show a mother
writes an article for the new york times
confessing that she has intentionally
traumatized her young children over
covid
and she doesn't appear to be sorry about
it also five headlines including the
start of trump's impeachment trial
a school system in maryland hopes to
make its students safer by defunding
these school resource officers and
the mayor of tampa pledges to hunt down
anyone who celebrated the super bowl
without a mask
she's going to find them and make them
pay and i'll cancel another tick tocker
always fun plus i'll read my youtube
comments and much more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know a good night's sleep without a
good pillow is
it's just not a thing it doesn't exist
it's like trying to it's like it's like
a good sandwich
with stale bread doesn't exist a lot of
people don't understand that
the bread is the star of the sandwich
and it really comes down to the to the
bread most but that's not the point
anyway
um my pillow is the point when it comes
to sleep
you're not gonna get a good night's
sleep unless you have a nice pillow
and my pillow products they really they
really are just it's a great pillow i
i mean that sincerely i don't know how
else to put it to you
just buy the pillow and try for yourself
they don't go flat you can wash and dry
them as many times as you want
and they maintain their shape and best
of all they're made in the usa
um if you don't have a my pillow now's
the time to try one
and it's not like any other pillow that
you've had you might you might think ah
pillow's a pillow
how special can it be well you haven't
tried a my pillow yet
uh so if you haven't had one or if you
know someone who hasn't tried my pillow
now is the time to get one
because for a limited time my pillow is
offering their premium my pillows for
their lowest price ever you can get a
queen size
premium my pillow regularly 69.98 for
only 29.98 that's 40 bucks in savings
and kings are only five dollars more so
this is the savings you can get
now is the time to buy you don't want to
wait until they're back up at full price
not only are you getting the lowest
price ever but they're the best gifts
ever uh we
do a valentine's day coming up right
around the corner
you might want to think about getting
your um getting your
your sweetheart a pillow uh 29.98 for a
queen size premium my pillow buy now and
they'll extend the 60-day
back guarantee to march first 2021 go to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
square
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
all
all of that you can get right now all
you have to do is call 800-651-1148 and
use promo code daily wire
a recent article in the new york times
encapsulates in the very first sentence
one of the great problems with how our
society has chosen to deal with the
coronavirus it's a problem i've talked
about a lot on the show
except written by someone who does not
seem to see it as a problem
the author courtney zofnis writes in the
first sentence
quote i have spent the past 11 months
filling my children with
fear with fear what follows is a long
paranoid diary entry presented for
public consumption for whatever reason
all revolving around courtney zoftness's
attempts to grapple with her
six-year-old son's
recent positive chronovirus test result
now we should note at the outset that
her son is not seriously ill
okay very few children his age
thankfully thank god have been made
seriously ill by the virus
she says that he is asymptomatic in fact
but this does not calm her fears fears
for her own safety not his she explains
that she has
hammered the dangers of the chronovirus
into both of her children's heads
her two sons ages six and nine know
quote
what the chronovirus is and how it
infects and how many people have died
and continue to die daily in the united
states
so our six and nine-year-old kids know
they know the number of people
dying every day of the virus she
satisfied that quote
he gets it which is why she proudly
reports
he quote washes his hands so often that
his knuckles have turned red and raw
yet he still got sick well not really
sick but covet positive anyway
her description of receiving the bad
news reads like something
i mean it really reads like something
that a parent of a child with cancer
might have written
this is what she says he doesn't believe
me at first
i hardly believe me it's january 21st
barely 7 a.m
maybe it's all a dream my son looks from
me to his father then back again
he had the most reliable tests his
brother his older brother cups his hands
over his mouth in disbelief
how my son says voice wobbly
i don't want to have kova he cries will
i die he says
will you no no she doesn't tell us how
she answered
that question but the correct answer is
no
son you will not die and neither will i
everything's going to be fine you're
going to be fine everything's okay
here let's here's some ice cream that's
the correct answer to a six-year-old
in this situation now that would be the
correct answer to give a child
even if he was seriously sick but he's
not
so comfort and reassurance should be
very easily and quickly provided
it just doesn't sound like this poor kid
got either of those things
uh from this woman though she continues
i had wanted my children to be afraid of
this virus so that they'd be protected
so that our family and the community and
the world would be too
but i am also pretty naturally anxious
somebody who relies on therapy and
medication to breathe evenly
my children have seen me distraught over
seven day averages and uncautious loved
ones and an immoral president who helped
accelerate the spread
the size of my son's sob is proportional
to the extra-large
apprehension i sowed into him for 11
months
how can this be unraveled well it can be
unraveled courtney
all the efforts that you've made to
protect them it can be unraveled because
we are facing a virus
you know not a horde of vikings so you
can't dig a moat and bolt the doors and
expect to keep
the virus out well i mean you can i
guess and as long as you stay in your
fortress the virus
probably won't get you but 11 months is
a long time to stay locked away
you're gonna have to go out into society
into society and so will your child
and the virus will be there when you
emerge as you have discovered
this is why cultivating fear in your
child will do nothing to protect him
fear just makes more fear fear begets
fear that's all it does
he is still just as likely or unlikely
to get sick
all you've ensured is that if and when
he does get sick he'll be scared to
death
now zofna says that she isolated her
sick child after the
the positive result she isolated him in
the house
had him wear apparently had him wear a
mask inside the house
and she wore one inside the house
wouldn't go near
him for presumably multiple days
she admits that she's not scared for him
but
of him her concern again is for her own
safety not his
she says quote but it occurs to me now
that we're not actually so worried about
him suffering physically or even heaven
forbid dying
we're worried about the adults he might
infect we are worried about each other
this is the reason they keep their
scared confused little boy locked away
isolated from the rest of the members of
the family they give him an area of the
house to himself a folding table to
attend remote school
he's like a prisoner in his home though
it seems you know that's not a major
change from how he's been forced to live
over the past year the only difference
now is that his mother is treating him
like a leper rather than simply treating
the rest of humanity like lepers and
teaching him to do the same
the article ends on a note that couldn't
possibly ring more hollow she says
i can't promise that i exuded calm in
the moment my youngest reached out to me
as much as i wanted to tried to but what
i could supply
without pretense was comfort
comfort if this is comfort courtney i'd
hate to see what you'd do
if you were trying to traumatize the
poor kid
now as far as we know um
speaking in my own family as i'm reading
this and thinking about our own
experiences
as far as we know in my family covid has
not hit our house yet unless it did and
we were asymptomatic as most people are
when they get it
but as far as we know it hasn't but my
wife and i have always understood
and accepted that if somebody in the
house gets sick we're all probably going
to get sick
it's just probably what's going to
happen sure you know if one of the
adults gets it we'll do our best to
isolate because we can do that as adults
that's a sacrifice that
we can make i got the flu back last
february really bad case of it
well i thought it was the flu maybe it
wasn't as it turns out but
anyway i spent three or four days
basically locked in a in our room very
sick i didn't want to get the kids sick
and so that's what i did i'm an adult i
can do that that's the sacrifice that i
can make a sacrifice my
wife had to make as well she's caring
for the kids all that time
but if a child gets it
and this is what my wife and i have
understood if one of the kids gets it
there's no way in hell we're confining
them like
death row inmates for a week and a half
and i'm not going to refuse
to go near my own child i'm just not
going to do that i would rather get
coveted
i would much rather get covert than
treat my children that way
if my son is scared and traumatized i
think he's gonna die
and he's he's being and he's isolated
and if
i i would rather go give him comfort
personally
and just get covered myself that's what
i would rather do
protecting our children's psychological
well-being providing them comfort and
assurance
being there for them emotionally and
physically that matters
i mean it matters a lot it matters so
much that it's worth getting sick to do
it matters more than our own physical
safety
especially when the threat to our
physical safety as parents of young
children
which presumably means you know if
you're a parent of a young child you're
probably under 50 years old at least
which means the threat to your physical
safety from covid is
probably minimal um
or it's certainly not as high as it is
for other groups
i will say this article is an extreme
example
perhaps but it it represents a trend a
common thread that we've seen present
itself throughout the last year adults
who are so scared for their own safety
so distraught about their own situation
that they willingly pull their own
children
into their paranoia i mean it is
appalling and weak and selfish and
disgraceful
all notions of dignity of courage and
strength have just been
abandoned all at once now i've i've um
i shouldn't say all at once we've been
abandoning those things in this culture
for a long time but this has accelerated
the process
i've mentioned i think once before on
this podcast a long time a long time ago
a story
recounted by sgt easton in the first
volume of his gulag archipelago which is
a memoir
history book about the labor camp system
in the soviet union a great book that
you should read in fact it's three books
it's three three volumes
but he tells a story i think in the
first volume about a guy named
sorghum who was in a prison camp and
on the day his wife was headed to visit
him
he found out that it was his turn to be
brought before the firing squad
and killed but he wanted to see his wife
one last time and and he didn't want her
to come
to the prison camp only to discover that
he'd already died
so um he begged the guards to hold off
on the execution just so that he could
give his wife this last visit i mean it
was really something he did for her
because he's gonna be dead so this is
really something he wants his wife to
have that
those last moments with him they agreed
to allow him to do this but the deal was
that he couldn't tell her that he was
about to die
couldn't tell her violating this rule
you could imagine in the soviet union
would have put his wife in danger
because as the family of a person in
prison in soviet union
you weren't allowed to know what's going
on with them and if you found out then
now you're a
national security risk too so he agreed
uh and she visited and he spent three
days with her morning noon and night
never once hinted never indicated that
he was in his last moments of life
and when the time came for her to leave
said goodbye she boarded the boat
and he got undressed and went off to be
shot
now think about the extreme self-control
the courage the dignity the strength the
love for his wife
that was required to keep his own
upcoming demise to himself
and spend time with her without
mentioning it
so i think about that story a lot
especially recently
as so many adults parents spouses now
cannot even deal with the extremely
unlikely chance that maybe they get sick
and maybe become one of the unlucky ones
and get seriously sick and maybe even
die
it's not a likely occurrence
but they can't deal with that so many
adults with no strength
no courage no dignity who have let this
fear
overwhelm them to the point that they
offload it even on their own young
children i can't imagine
doing that to my kids my kids went like
six months
and didn't hadn't even heard the word
coveted they didn't even know what it
was
and now they they're familiar with the
word they've heard it but uh
it's they're not overcome with fear
they're not paranoid about it
at all because i'm not going to put that
on them i just think if these people
were
in say a sorgen's position they would
have collapsed into tears and spilled
the beans
15 seconds after their wife arrived and
then she'd be in front of the firing
line too
this inability to keep things in
perspective this overriding paranoia
fueled by selfishness and cowardice
this failure to protect children protect
them mentally and emotionally
this damage that we're doing to the
youngest generation because we're scared
and feel helpless
this is all what will define our present
moment in history
i wish i could say it'll be defined by
our resilience and strength and
all that good american stuff
but the really tough truth is that we're
just not that kind of country
anymore let's get to our five headlines
all right so there's the you know this
debate about um
who's the greatest athlete ever in
history now that's
it's people having this debate on online
and they're having on espn who's
it's it's really a silly debate because
you're you know you're comparing across
sports and across generations
it's it's really kind of stupid was babe
ruth
better than tom brady what um
but i don't know it's it's still
interesting and really part of the fun
of being a sports fan is to have
completely pointless debates like this
if you enjoy having pointless frivolous
debates
and you're not a sports fan you should
be that's one of the reasons that i am
because that's what i love to do debate
things that don't matter
uh it's what i've dedicated my life to
in fact
so this has been the debate and you know
i i i tend to
side with the people who say that the
best athlete in history or you know for
talking modern history
probably would have to be somebody in an
individual sport i mean tom brady
obviously is the best
football player of all time uh there's
really no debating that but
michael phelps individual sport all on
his own in the water swimming
he's got 23 gold medals second place
in history has nine okay he got almost
that many in one olympics
he's got how many total medals does he
have like 28 30 something like that
and he's competing against the entire
world and i think
you know they started counting gold
medals like in the 1900s
going back 120 years 120 years of
history the entire world and he's got
23 gold medals in second place is nine i
think probably that's the argument for
other people are saying somebody like
serena williams if you look at the way
that she's dominated the field
the only thing about the only thing i'll
say about that i don't mean this in a
sexist way but um
she can't be the greatest athlete in
history because she's competing against
girls
no offense and remember if i say no
offense then you're not allowed to be
offended by it
but that's also the i think we know it's
like the greatest athlete in history
obviously is at least a man that's to
begin with
and then you can go from there i'm sure
that'll be an uncontroversial statement
we can all agree all right
um moving on headlines number one
trump's senate impeachment trial starts
today
um i'm as uninterested in this
impeachment as
i was in the last one and that's pretty
much the end of my analysis of it
so instead i think number one will be
this i want to start with this actually
the mayor of tampa
says that she's she is hunting down
and looking for the evil doers who
didn't wear a mask
while celebrating the super bowl win so
she's like liam neeson and taken
and she will find you and she'll make
you pay but uh here she is let's listen
everyone knows that simply wearing a
mask
dramatically reduces the spread of covet
19.
and i'm proud to say that the majority
of individuals that i saw
out and about enjoying the festivities
associated with the super bowl
were complying you know we we had tens
of
thousands of people all over the city
downtown out by the stadium ybor city
uh down here in channel side and
very very few incidents so i'm proud of
our community
but those few bad actors will be
identified
and the tampa police department will
handle it there just has to be that
level of personal responsibility you can
supply everyone with a mask
advise them of the science behind it and
expect that they are going to to abide
by the
mask order again you're going to find a
few that don't
the majority that i saw were wearing
masks it's going to be really awkward
when they
arrest tom brady because
he was not wearing a mask a lot of
people weren't wearing a mask actually
both when they were competing in the
game but also afterwards during the
super bowl
the celebration the ceremony on the
field so you can arrest all them
something tells me not yeah so they're
going to be looking at
surveillance footage to go and track
down the people who weren't wearing a
mask so what we've learned in america
is that if you go out with a crowd and
burn down a police station
uh loot a walmart um
you know assault random pedestrians set
a cop car on fire
throw molotov cocktails at police
officers throw rocks
at uh through people's windows if you do
that then
they're not going to bother with you
know it's to look at the security camera
go find people that takes a lot of work
it's not a big deal anyway all you did
was burn down a police station
um but if you go walk down the street
without a mask
now you're a danger to the public and we
have to go find you all right number two
the
montgomery county parent teacher
association of maryland is pushing a
resolution that would defund
all student resource officers from
public schools
according to a copy copy of the
resolution obtained by the daily wire
the parent teacher association is
calling on the montgomery public county
public school district to discontinue
placing police officers on every high
school campus the pta also calls for the
district to reallocate the money spent
on student resource officers to mental
health services
and quote restorative justice practices
and then they go on to talk about the of
course the student resource officers
engage in
bias and discrimination against minority
students and students with disabilities
in a separate letter telemetry school
parents pta president alison
kozma claimed that student resource
resource officers were also biased
against lgbtq students
no examples or proof is given but well
of course
you know it's something that we think is
bad and so if they're bad then they must
also be biased against
lgbt people we don't need an example of
it they just are
comes with the territory of being bad
now the thing is if if they weren't so
set on turning everything into a racial
and bigotry situation
there are valid concerns you could raise
about having police officers in the
school
there there are valid concerns um one of
the concerns
is that when a police officer gets
involved
it becomes a legal matter and that's
where you find
you know there have been we've seen the
videos of like eight-year-old kids
um element at least elementary school
age at least
just being disruptive in school and then
they get carted away they're at least
but a few
cases they're just getting carted away
in handcuffs
and arrested i mean and this is what
happens when you get the police involved
this is what the police do
and that is a concern you know i'm not a
fan of that
i think the schools need security every
single school you think about all the
public school system
that's a government building you might
not like thinking of it that way if you
send your kid into that into the school
you might not you might not like to
think of it like you're you're sending
your children into a
government building for seven hours a
day but you are
and most other government buildings have
have security you go to the social
security office
there's gonna be an armed guard sitting
there to what protect papers
you know i would think if it's a
government building that has
documents that are important or people
that are important
like capitol hill or if it has money or
anything like that then there's gonna be
armed security
well here's government building with
with our children inside it
and i think our children are more
important than all of the
previously listed entities
uh in fact i you know i think it's more
important to protect our kids than even
politicians i think we should protect
them both but
but i i think as a society our number
one priority
period should be protecting kids that's
our number one and then everybody else
comes after
me you everyone politician so yes we
should have we should have security in
these schools
um but having police officers involved
in
the normal kind of rule breaking and and
rough housing that you find in schools i
think there's a
there is an issue with that then again
you could argue
well yeah but this is this is a
government building and uh
if you don't want the government to
handle it like the government does then
maybe you shouldn't send your kid into
school so there's a discussion to be had
there
but we can't really have that discussion
because
it all has to come down to race and
bigotry and discrimination
so the actual point as always is missed
by a million miles
um let's see
also from the daily wire a wisconsin
middle school placed a small group of
teachers on leave after they purchased
and distributed a lesson plan
that asked 11 year olds how they would
punish slaves
on the first first day of black history
month a sixth grader
sixth graders at patrick marsh middle
school were asked how they would punish
a disobedient slave during an online
assignment
according to a screenshot of the of the
class were obtained obtained by newsweek
students were asked to describe how they
would punish a slave
that said you are not my master. here's
how the scenario reads
a slave stands before you this slave has
disrespected his master by telling him
you are not my master
how will you punish this slave the
assignment provides a box
for students to detail their answers now
the the context here and we know that
context like we learned yesterday
context doesn't matter at all anymore
which means that you just cannot come to
fair judgments about anything if context
doesn't matter
but if you are one of those
crazy bigoted people who thinks that
context still does matter well here's
the context
they were talking about ancient
mesopotamian
laws and they were describing
what the rules were the unjust rules for
slaves
and that's that was the point it wasn't
like encouraging students to go
take slaves and abuse them it was it was
simply describing what slavery was going
back in history
the ways that it was unjust that
you would think that it's we want our
kids to learn that
that's something that kids should learn
but for all the claims that what the
the left says well we're this is not
we're we're not attacking history we're
not trying to get rid of history all
we're saying is
take the monuments down put them in a
museum this is not an attack on history
no it is it is an attack on history
there are entire
swaths of not just american extreme but
world history
they simply don't want kids to learn
anymore
all right number four represent
representative maxine waters who
famously told her supporters to
find trump administration officials and
form a crowd
and confront them is now defending
herself
saying that she actually has has not
contributed to political violence even
though she said that she hasn't
contributed political violence
and this is how she defends it uh let's
listen already
you have members of your cabinet that
are being booed out of restaurants
they have protesters picking up at their
house
and guess what we're gonna win this
battle because while you try
and quote the bible jeff sessions and
others you really don't know
the bible god is on our side
on the side of the children on the side
of what's right
on the side of what's honorable on the
side of
understanding that if we can't protect
the children
we can't protect anybody and so
let's save the course let's make sure we
show up
wherever we have to show up and if you
see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not
welcome
okay so that's what she said a couple of
years ago and
i don't know well in fact i do know
that's that sounds like you're
encouraging violence you're
you're telling them to this is not just
trump supporters but
administration officials are being
encouraged
or there she's encouraged the crowd to
find them form a crowd
form a crowd and let them know they're
not welcome
what when when it when an angry group of
people
forms a crowd to uh communicate to a
person that they're not welcome
how how is that opinion conveyed
normally
it is always through violence or at
least through the threat of violence
through the explicit or implicit
threat of violence so that's what she
said but then she was asked about this
uh
yesterday and uh here's the defense that
she offered
can you say that you have not glorified
or encouraged violence against
republicans
absolutely i can say it as a matter of
fact if you look at the words that i use
the strongest thing i said was tell them
they're not welcome
talk to them tell them they're not
welcome i didn't say
go and fight i didn't say anybody was
going to have any violence
and so they can't make that state so
it's as simple as that really when
you're i guess when you're a democrat
all you have to do is you can say
something
and this is the great thing about having
the media on your side you could say
something
and then your defense says i didn't say
that well but you did we have it on no i
didn't say it
didn't say it jedi mind trick didn't say
it
and then the media moves on the most
they'll do is press you one time
well but i think you said it because no
i didn't all right well if you say so
it's got to be nice all right number
five finally a big legal controversy a
woman named
tessica brown not jessica tessica
is thinking about suing the
manufacturers of gorilla glue after
spraying the glue
in her hair um because uh she she didn't
have hairspray i guess
and so she sprayed the glue in fact here
she is explaining i i'm not gonna
explain for her i don't know how this
happened but
here is tessa brown explaining why she's
sprayed
uh glue in her hair listen hey y'all
for those of y'all that know me know my
hair has been like this for about a
month now
it's not by choice no
it's not a choice when i do my hair i
like to
you know finish it off with a little got
to be glue spray you know just to
keep it in place well i didn't have any
more got to be glue space so i use this
gorilla glue spray
bad bad idea
yo look my hair it don't move
you hear them telling you it don't move
i've washed my hair 15.
times and it don't move
stiff wear whoa
my hair so i'm gonna tell y'all like
this if you
ever ever run out of got to be glue
spray
don't ever ever use this
that's good advice i'm glad she
mentioned that because
i cannot tell you how many times i have
been tempted
by the siren song of gorilla
glue spray i mean we've all been in
situations like this
in fact recently i was in the shower and
i didn't have a
washcloth so i yelled to my wife said
can you give me a washcloth and she said
oh we don't have any washcloths
uh they're all in the they're all
they're all dirty but
i do have this belt sander and i said
sure i'll
i guess i'll use that instead and it was
a mistake it's
very unpleasant to bathe yourself with a
belt sander in the shower
um so you know we all we all make
mistakes sometimes in life
and this is the mistake that she made
now she uh
she tmz reports on this story says our
sources say
tessica i just like it that sources they
have sources on the story of the woman
who sprayed glue in her hair
they've got undercover sources our
sources say tessica spent 22 hours
in the er and the staff was dumbfounded
we're told healthcare workers put you
know did everything they could
to get the stuff off her head but what
they tried to do it burned her scalp it
only made the glue
gooey before hardening back up testica
rotolo was instructed to keep trying the
potential remedy back home but rubbing
alcohol still
hasn't provided a cure our sources say
that tessica's
had now has hired an attorney and you
saw this part coming she is now weighing
her legal options against gorilla glue
uh and here's the thing so she's gonna
sue gorilla
glue because she sprayed it in her hair
and it does say right on the bottle
this is glue that's what this is
okay there's there's nothing on the
bottle that indicates this is for hair
if it's said on the bottle put this in
your hair like some kind of practical
joke by the gorilla glue people then i
would say
yeah definitely sue i mean even
i don't know if if if um if you bought
it at walmart or something and
and they put it in the wrong section
they put it in the hairspray aisle
maybe you have a case against walmart
but i don't think that's the case here
so you think to yourself there's there's
no way she could win this lawsuit
but shoot if she doesn't win it
this woman is going to make millions of
dollars
mark my words right now she is coming
out of this thing with
minimum six figures but i'm thinking
millions from this
because apparently the um
there is a disclaimer on the back of the
uh the the
can of glue but the disclaimer says
do not use on eyes skin or clothing
that's what it says never said anything
about hair
and this is the mistake that companies
make like they they assumed
that even someone dumb enough to spray
it in their eyes
wouldn't be so dumb as the sprayed in
their hair and so they didn't mention
that part of it
or they assume that everyone is smart
enough to kind of connect the dots
like they thought well there's only so
many levels of dumb you can be right if
you know most people are smart enough
that they'll see that bottle and just
they know what it is and it's glue
they're not going to spray it on any
part of their body but then they figured
well if you're
you know okay if you're so dumb that
you'd even be tempted to spray it
and then and then you flip it around you
read the back of the bottle
and we say don't put it on skin don't
put it on eyes don't put it on clothing
well you'll get the you'll get the point
at that you know at that juncture
you'll understand nobody could be so
dumb that even then
they still would spread but no there's
always someone dumb enough there's one
thing we've learned about society
and so yeah i would expect a lot of
discomfort
but she's gonna get the last laugh here
she's gonna have that
hard crusty hair for the rest of her
life she'll never be able to change her
hairstyle
but she'll be rich all right let's go uh
let's move on now to our
newest and most exciting segment which
is reading the youtube comments
and this is the segment where i well
read some of the comments under on on
youtube from the previous show so
sinistar says matt did you forget to
include the read the comments section
i really enjoyed that edition i did
forget
but mind your own business all right
pera consistent jojo says
this whole episode was and then there's
a fire emoji and i thank you for that
but you know my rules about emojis
they're not allowed so you are banned
from
listening to the show from this day
forward unfortunately i have to enforce
the rules
uh gary teague says who has the best
beard matt walsh or stephen crowder vote
now on the daily wire or louder with
crowder we have nothing else to do
well i you know look i i'm not one
to uh puff myself up but i i i think i
can say that i have the best beard in
conservative media period can't i say
that who
who else is really even in the running
i've had this beard for a long time
okay i've been working on this for a
long time i put a lot of my heart and
soul and energy into this
and so i'm going to claim that title for
myself i think i deserve that much at
least
um nick s says now he's reacting to
my claim yesterday you know there's this
this uh the reboot of the equalizer with
queen latifah as the new action hero and
she's a 50 year old woman and you know i
made the point that
it's just sort of hard to take a 50 year
old woman seriously in in this
was supposed to be a gritty intimidating
action hero type of role
and nick s has a a good point he says
hey now matthew have we forgotten about
kill bill
the bride was pissing your boots effing
scary i think most of us were perfectly
willing to dispense with reality
while watching that flick it really
depends on how it's done
why it's done and what message the film
is meant to send out yeah so
that might be one of the only examples
that i can think there'll be a couple
others but there's
that's one example of very few
where someone made uh quentin tarantino
in this case made
basically a female action hero
who was actually like intimidating you
wouldn't want to mess with her
but it's it's really hard to do because
you
you have to get the tone exactly right
quen tarantino can do it and so in that
in that really specific particular kind
of quentin tarantino cinematic universe
you can do that but if you're not
quentin tarantino what we discovered is
it's hard to pull off
and what ends up happening most of the
time is that
if you're a filmmaker you're making the
show and you're going for the gritty
intimidating thing
it just ends up being sort of silly
um finally elena says i find it
interesting and also very telling about
our society that canceled culture is
basically the exact
opposite of confession in the catholic
church the sacrament of confession
requires one to out of their own free
will and real contrition
privately confess their sins to a priest
then god who is won
truly wrong by our sins forgives and we
go on to do private penance
our society however will perceive an
action as as wrong and use public
humiliation to force an apology
out of the person whether they are truly
sorry or not the apology
is never accepted and forgiveness is
never offered the person is only forced
into a public penance that usually
involves a ruined reputation
and the loss of opportunities that um
would have otherwise they would have
otherwise deserved it's honestly sick
bring back christian forgiveness
yeah that's the whole problem with the
entire spectacle we talked about
yesterday
of the public apology that there's no
real contrition because the person who's
giving the public apology isn't actually
sorry and oftentimes
they shouldn't be sorry because what
they are being cancelled for um
at least in one of the cases the you
know the new york times editor he used a
certain word in a certain context
referring to the word he wasn't using it
in a in a racist context
and he offered the public apology anyway
so whatever the case is
when you're being forced into giving an
apology publicly
almost certainly you are not giving it
because you're actually sorry you're
giving it because you're trying to
salvage your reputation
feudally it's not going to work so
there's no real contrition there's no
opportunity for forgiveness
because the people you're apologizing to
they don't care about the apology
they're not even going to listen to it
or take it into consideration
um so there's it's just nothing there's
there's nothing happening there other
than this
this pageant this charade
which in the end serves the interests of
of power for
the cancel culture mob so they can claim
you as a trophy
and that's all that is quick word now
from our good friends at rock auto
you know we're always looking for the
most affordable option you know which
isn't to say cheap there's a difference
between especially when you're shopping
for
auto parts there's a difference between
cheap and affordable cheap
is not always a good thing that's
something that's gonna that's that's not
gonna work for you it's gonna break down
um affordable you know that that's a
totally different ball game and that's
what you get
from rockauto.com you go to rockauto.com
you're gonna find
all the different parts for your car or
truck and you have access to it
rockauto.com at your desk in your pocket
it's so much easier than going into an
auto parts store
and what you're going to find from
rockauto.com a family business serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
what you'll find is auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all
the prices as i said are reliably low
very affordable
uh but great quality and you're finding
you're gonna find
whatever it is you're looking for you're
gonna find there you're gonna find it
for the best
possible price you could expect amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts
that your car will ever need at
rockauto.com
so here's what you need to do go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and
remember please
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
and also um you've heard me talk about
our all-access membership before
but for those of you who haven't heard
me talk about it
it's our most elite membership tier
these are these are the people that we
we love all of our we love we love the
whole audience
but there are some that we just love a
little bit more let's be honest and
that's got to be the all-access the
elite i'm just speaking for myself here
but um as an elitist but the elite
membership tiers all access our all
access members
receive two leftist tiers tumblers when
they sign up and being an all-access
member means
they get to watch full coverage of all
daily wire shows not to mention
our feature film and soon to come
entertainment content so many other
great things what's more
they get to tune into the exclusive all
access live a show featuring a different
daily wire host every day
a casual conversation which is a lot of
fun so today we want to publicly thank
all of our all access members for their
commitment to the daily wire and to show
our appreciation
we are mailing out a special anniversary
tumbler for all
renewing all access members this year
and this is the tumblr
without the damn sloth once again um on
the front you've got the classic
leftist tiers and on the back all of our
signatures
as well the main thing you want to focus
on though
is the the matt walsh signature right
there and oh yeah the other guys too
we got all that and also a short
statement about our belief
that america's best days are still ahead
of us
i don't know if i really actually
believe that so
maybe i'll maybe i'll write or maybe
i'll write word doomed on a few of the
cups and we'll send those out too
um i'm not really gonna do that but this
is a commemorative piece for our
five-year journey and thank you to all
of our all access members in particular
for supporting who we are and what we do
so make sure you renew your membership
and get your all access to your
your new leftist tears tumbler now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation i'm
afraid that we must go once again
and plunge the depraved depths of the
cyber sewage dump known as tick tock
i've been accused of leaning too heavily
on tick-tock for my cancellations
but first of all again mind your own
business second of all
there's there's just a lot of
intentionally unintentionally not
intentionally but unintentionally
hilarious stuff there and third
this is the app that the kids are using
and being influenced by so at a certain
point we have to stop
with this really kind of foolish thing
of acting like
the content that our kids not my kids
but a lot of people's kids spend hours a
day ingesting is somehow frivolous and
unimportant
it may be stupid it may be embarrassing
but it's not frivolous because
because it it's what's helping to shape
the next generation for better or worse
and in this case worse with that said we
have to cancel a guy named ryan
mccarten um or ryan mccarron one of the
two
anyway he has a huge following on tick
tock and apparently as an actor
or something and uh there's one video in
particular that puts him in line to be
canceled today
but going through his catalog as i did
it seems that
many tick tock users come to him for
advice and wisdom
and he's eager to offer it so as an
example of that here's a here's a recent
video
where he gives his mind-blowing totally
unique perspective
on the abortion debate you're not going
to believe this listen
so there are three parts of this
conversation to me the science of
abortion the history abortion and the
debate about abortion i want to talk
about the debate right now but let me
know if you want to hear the other stuff
the debate about abortion is are you
pro-choice or pro-life and that just
sets up a false dichotomy because the
opposite of pro-life is anti-life no one
is
anti-life and we aren't actually talking
about life we're talking about birth so
then the debate would be pro-birth or
anti-birth and that doesn't make any
sense either
so you go back to our original terms
choice i think that's what the debate is
about are you pro-choice or are you
anti-choice and the thing that just
really
bothers me about this argument a is that
liberals have succumbed to this idea of
arguing with a pro-life stance when
we're not talking about life we're
talking about choice
but also the conservative thinking in
america is all about limiting government
to not
step in on our individual liberties to
make our own choices about our lives so
i don't understand why liberals and
conservatives aren't actually on the
same page about this the government
should not make any choices about what
we do with our individual liberties
regarding our own bodies no matter who
we are what we look like or what our
bodies do
wow wow just incredible
so so so he he wants to let me see if i
got this correctly
he wants to reframe the debate as
pro-choice or anti-choice
i have never heard that before i mean
this this is completely altered the way
i view this issue
i have simply never heard someone make
the anti-choice point before
it's it's amazing no one's ever said
this that's why this guy's so proud of
himself
when he makes this point you know i've
been thinking about this i think
this is about choice huh
this man is a philosopher for the ages
if socrates came across this guy
socrates would poison himself again just
because he's so depressed
that he'll never be as smart and
insightful as ryan mccarten
or mccarran all that said um yes
actually the issue is about life the
fundamental question is whether the baby
in the womb is a human life and whether
as a human life it has the same moral
worth
and is therefore entitled to the same
legal protections as
a born person now i say yes if ryan
mccartney says no
he should explain why his answer is no
but people on the anti-life side rarely
want to defend that part of their
argument
now as for the government not telling us
what to do with our bodies well okay
then
so i assume you're an avid anti-massacre
in that case
that's the government telling you what
to do with your with your body oh but
that's different you say it's different
because
if you don't wear a mask you could harm
somebody else
ah okay so so you can do what you want
with your body
up to the point where you're potentially
inflicting harm on another person
hmm well the unborn
human who is poisoned dismembered or
decapitated
through the course of the abortion would
you say that qualifies as
harm oh but that's different you say
because the unborn human
doesn't count well what do you know
we're right back to a debate about life
in its definition
which is exactly what you said the
debate is not about but it turns out
that is what the debate is always about
it can't be about anything else
so that's ryan mccartney on abortion now
let's hear what he has to say about
racism i am the oppressor i
am racist oh my god he just said he's
racist it shouldn't be this hard you
guys
if you live in america went to school
participate in the socioeconomic
structures participate in any sort of
system
education business entertainment what
have you and you are white
you are indoctrinated you are oppressive
and yes you are racist it is something
that we have
learned either consciously or
subconsciously all of us as white
americans
and what we have to do is unlearn that
i'm trying to do the work
part of doing the work is pushing
against dangerous narratives that are
counter-intuitive to that unlearning
like
white people are also oppressed by
racism we're not
we are the oppressors that's the point
you should be doing the unlearning too
do the work i love this guy's dance
moves the choreography while he makes
his point i don't know what all this you
can't see it if you're listening to
audio podcasts but he's got a certain
move that he does
he's like it's like it's like watching
in sync or something in the 90s
it's all the all the choreography but um
first of all if i live my whole life and
never again hear the phrase do the work
from somebody who does not appear to
have ever done any kind of work
at all in their lives i will die a happy
man second
i'm not gonna spend a lot of time
debunking this notion that only white
people are racist because
only they have systemic power yada yada
et cetera
i've addressed that many times and as
i've explained it is built on numerous
false assertions starting with the idea
that power has anything necessarily to
do with racism
and also the idea that only white people
have systemic power
we can look around right now and see
every major corporation bending over
backwards to affirm the most radical
tenets
of blm orthodoxy we could see that the
same is true of politicians and
bureaucrats and
almost everybody who wields serious
power in this country we can also see
that
the only form of explicit racial
systemic bias
that's allowed in this country is the
kind that cuts against white people like
affirmative action
all of that is clear so this from ryan
mccarten and those like him
is nothing but a doctrinal statement
it's not based on any kind of evidence
or logic
except an internal logic within the
critical race theory cult
and even there internally there isn't
much logic to it
just remember anytime somebody says only
white people can be racist
all you have to do is respond with one
question this is what i would respond
with
says who oh only white people can be
racist
okay says who who says that
you do but where are you getting that
from why should i accept
your definition of racism i understand
that that's your claim that's your
belief but
why should i give a damn why should i
believe it
and i guess if you want to follow up
with another question you could also ask
this
did racism exist a thousand years ago
two thousand years ago three thousand
years did it exist in ancient times
did racism exist back when people were
slaughtering and enslaving outsiders
just as a matter of course
because because if racism is inherent to
white people because of their systemic
power then it must mean that racism
didn't exist before white people as we
know them now
existed or before they had this kind of
power i mean i mean you go back through
history and um
you find that the most powerful empires
back in ancient times were in places
like egypt and mesopotamia
was there no racism then was it an
anti-racist utopia which just so
happened to subsist on slavery and
conquest
so that's a question you could ask but
what i want to focus on
is uh is something else at a deeper
level is the guilt
you know i've long suspected that one of
the things that makes this all white
people a racist idea appealing
is the way that it explains and channels
guilt
now for non-white people the appeal is
pretty straightforward they're absolved
of racism permanently
and they're positioned as the automatic
good guy in any dispute with a white
person
that's a hell of a deal if you can get
it but for white people part of the
appeal i think is is religious in nature
what is it that that will often times
you think about wha what will oftentimes
get a person to go to church
after a long time away they're feeling
burdened
by their sin feeling guilty they're
looking for absolution for something to
they want something to do with this
guilt that they're carrying around
but with theistic religion receding and
with many of the remaining churches too
afraid to talk about guilt and sin
anyway
things like critical race theory step
into the gap
jesus says come to me all who are
burdened and i will give you rest
well those who are burdened and not
going to jesus have to go somewhere else
crt critical race theory is a substitute
for some people only it's not going to
offer rest or absolution instead it just
offers more guilt but at least
it explains and clarifies the guilt or
claims to
it puts everything in racial terms and
gives confused and desperate people
a framework for understanding themselves
and their own
internal struggles the framework is
wrong and evil
but hey at least it's a framework to
paraphrase
the big lebowski all that said
the the other possible explanation
so i mean all that just maybe that's why
if i want to go to a real deep
like psychological philosophical level
uh maybe that's why someone like ryan
mccartney is so eager to call himself
racist
maybe the other possible explanation for
why ryan mccarthy says he's racist
is that he's actually racist i mean that
is what he's saying maybe we should just
take him seriously
maybe when a white person gets up and
says i'm racist
we should just say oh okay well sorry to
hear about that
and then when he says yeah but all of
you are too we we say not me
i don't know man speak for yourself uh
you already said it you've
you've cli you've made your claim i'm
not joining you i'm i'm not giving you
any cover
here so hate to hear about that i'm
sorry
shouldn't be racist that sucks man i
you know thanks for telling us
just because you are doesn't mean that i
am ryan speak for yourself
and maybe in the end maybe maybe that is
the one
needed response to the critical race
theory cultist
speak for yourself also
you're canceled so those two things
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. athletes vie
for the title of greatest of all time
mitt romney proposes an entitlement
program that many conservatives love
and even a democrat senator admits the
impeachment trial
may not be legit check it out on the
michael knowles show
you